qué posición hay que adoptar frente a
las tres juntas militares en el poder en
malí guinea y burkina faso tras el
fracaso de la primera reunión celebrada
hace un mes en ghana se espera que los
líderes de la cedeao adopten una postura
en el caso de malí el único país con un
embargo económico total durante seis
meses los últimos hechos han allanado el
camino para que se relajen las sanciones
el miércoles bamako hizo público el
calendario electoral que había exigido
la cedeao
para las elecciones legislativas la
primera vuelta será el domingo 29 de
octubre de 2023 la primera vuelta para
elegir al presidente de la república
será el domingo 4 de febrero de 2024
en el rancho caps dos semanas antes se
había aprobado una nueva ley electoral y
creado una comisión encargada de
redactar una nueva constitución un
referendo constitucional que está
previsto para marzo de 2023 anuncios
calificados como enormes progresos por
el equipo de goodluck jonathan el ex
presidente nigeriano que está mediando
entre la junta maliense y la cedeao
hasta ahora a guinea conakry burkina
faso sólo han sido suspendidos del
organismo pero a diferencia de mal y
ahora los dos países se exponen al
endurecimiento de sus sanciones en ambos
casos el anuncio de un período de
transición de 36 meses no ha gustado a
los dirigentes de la cedeao desde guinea
conakry han intentado mostrar buena
voluntad para evitar el destino del
vecino maliense ya hemos creado un
consejo interministerial a un grupo de
es que lo perfeccionaremos a medida que
avancemos mientras desde la oposición
guineana piden un mediador del organismo
en burkina ya ha nombrado a un mediador
el ex presidente nigeriano o mamadou
issoufou el sábado estuvo en uagadugú
donde se celebró la apertura al diálogo
de los militares burkineses pero la
propuesta electoral de la junta con un
referendo constitucional en diciembre de
2024 y elecciones en febrero de 2025
está demasiado lejos para la cedeao